all right my first question is for both
of you because I know you did a sailing
boot camp for this movie and David I
know you had a little experience you had
an advantage in that department but for
both of you of all the skills you
learned during that boot camp what came
most naturally to you but then I want
the opposite the part of that boot camp
that was the most challenging for you to
pick up on for me because I did have an
experience I I was a professional
fisherman when I was in my early 20s in
Alaska and the thing that came easily to
me which surprises me because I'm from
the farm country of Kansas was that my
sea legs came on quickly like I was able
to always keep my balance pretty well on
a ship no matter how it was pitching and
um that's really useful especially when
you're trying to work under rugged
circumstances you're trying to go the
thing that was always the most
challenging for me and it has been since
I was a little boy from scouts all the
way to today I can barely tie my shoes
let alone tie a good knot and I was
watching the rest of my cast as we were
doing sailing training just throwing
these knots together Liam you were good
at it Chris was good at it Corey was
good at it and there I was like I don't
know there's something I just don't get
yeah it's a funny one uh we went yeah we
were in rostock on this gorgeous boat
with all the ropes and sails and all
that sort of thing and I was I think
David's been too kind to me I had a bit
of trouble with that little yellow rope
we were trying to do these nuts with but
I was asked by the instructors do you
want to go up and start pulling the
sails up and that sounded a bit too much
like work to me and I went nah he
wouldn't do it he's the captain he
doesn't pull ropes
um and they had no argument against that
so I sat back with a small glass of
white wine and watched my fellow cast
members getting blisters on their hands
while they were throwing themselves into
doing this I'm no fool you're the
smartest actor I've ever hey it serves
your character well I say go for it um I
know you both have worked on pretty
substantial sets before but is there
anything that you did on the Demeter
that just wow you in terms of what they
were actually capturing in camera versus
things you would expect them to be
accomplishing in post via VFX yes yes
wonderfully for instance a wonderful
performer a wonderful Dracula Javier
a lot of times you've got you know in a
lot of movies now because of the
advancements of computers and Ai and all
that sort of stuff you can have a guide
addressed like a mime with the little
dots all over them and you're to imagine
this horrific Beast we have this
incredible performer arrive on set
everybody expecting him because he was
going to be arriving uh for suit tests
and lighting tests fully done up and
when I eventually got to see him I was
actually scared when I saw my one that
is absolutely horrific some of the other
cast members including some of the crew
were saying I can't even look at them
when you've got that attention to detail
and when you've got a production design
like we have with those dark muted
colors that all that gothic stuff and
it's a painting a horror film of this
this thing is a painting everything has
to come together and when we have this
beautiful music on top of it you really
do feel part of of a movie of Cinema not
just getting your character right and
pleasing the director and all that sort
of stuff you felt part of the of the
large and that's incredibly satisfying
as an actor there's a moment when we're
making the film we were in Malta which
is where we did the exterior
um uh boat shots and uh there's this
fantastic Norwegian actor Martin furl
and who um plays Larson who's supposed
to be Manning uh the ship in night watch
and he's supposed to be at the wheel and
we hit it this crazy storm in the script
and it's a massive storm torrential rain
lightning flashing and crashing and
water waves crashing over the side of
the boat and Larson's nowhere to be seen
of course poor Larson uh has been one of
the first people to meet our Dear
Dracula but the rest of us come running
up to the deck of the ship in the midst
of this storm and there they were with
you know rain machines and water cannons
blasting us and and lighting effects to
create the lightning and
um it was so cool to feel like uh what
the magic of movies can accomplish and
yes we know it's all make believe and
we're sitting there and you see the
machinery and the amazing crew and the
riggers and the people running the crazy
fans
but you get lost in it and you just you
you feel like a kid you know there's no
limits to your imagination when you're
given that kind of a support system I'll
always use an extra uh opportunity to
shout out Javier botet because he is a
legend and everybody in this business
should know his name the one somewhat
silly question for both of you so let's
say you as in real you you suspect that
Dracula is hunting you who is someone in
your real life that you go and tell that
will actually believe you and help you
fight Dracula oh it set my wife on him
immediately she's fearsome and she'd
probably take him out or she'd give him
a really hard time a lot of respect for
that lady anybody else nah she's top of
the list I feel like that's good yeah my
my my wife would say uh good luck no
I've got uh I've got a six-year-old
daughter named Penelope uh but we call
her Penny and uh she is a force of
nature who I feel would absolutely go
um and she would she would hunt Dracula
down with me and then my son Arlo he's
he's got the mind for helping me come up
with the strategy for how we would trap
and kill him but they would believe me
everybody else uh would say oh David's
finally cracked or they've say maybe
he's cracked yet again but whatever
perfect answers I couldn't imagine
better picks for that question um
um Liam you'll get my one future project
question this time around because I have
three body problem on the brain because
they did just release the trailer for
that so having worked with Benny off and
Weiss of course on Game of Thrones what
do you think made the two of them
particularly well suited to also lead
that adaptation of a very popular book
series ooh listen it's always the
quality of the writing
uh on these guys uh some of the best
writing I've ever come across in my life
and this is also saying I spent a year
and a half the Royal Shakespeare company
I've done Shakespeare on stage these
boys are absolutely extraordinary the
words they put in an actor's mouth and
then to go with this and David's an
enormous fan of of the books I haven't
even read the books I didn't read the
Game of Thrones books either he knows a
lot more about it than I do and I meant
it it's just a raw deal I got screwed
Liam what the heck man no one called me
to be in three body problems it's true
life's not fair Davis life ain't Fair
um I was there to tell you the truth I
haven't told anybody else I was in
serious talks for another project and
obviously the boys found out about it
and I got a phone call
from the tube guy from David and Dan it
just said uh you're not you're not doing
that you come with us and I just went uh
I didn't even know what the project was
and I just said yeah okay I'll tell them
I'll tell the other crap now it could
have been a day's work on the other
thing but
when when those two call uh you uh you
run to the Clarion call I like here and
that and David don't worry you're mighty
busy this year you can't I don't think
you could cram in more films than you
already have congratulations to you both
on everything you've accomplished on
this film in particular right now and I
appreciate your time today lovely
talking to you thank you